と言うこんにちははじめしゃちょーでそまえら
8月5日何の日か知っていますでしょうか
サマージャンボ宝くじも
サマージャンボ宝くじの当選日でございます
ああああああああああああ
はいそれで僕はねあのー合致で使ってに行こうと思ってね以上20万円以下はせて
いただきました
いやぁ今回は6億ですよ6先に皆さんに謝っておくんですけど本当に
ごめんなさいん
僕ほどの境になるとね分かるんですよ
当たるときは安保かもまずで6月に行くんで
本当にばそこら辺の人いやみんな6ほしいと思うんだけど僕方が欲しい人いないんです
よ
申し訳ないです僕はちょっとこのこの動画を機に僕の人生はもう変法しますもうマジで
当てますから今日はマジでこれから衝撃動画になるからねほんとにサマー山ボート
サマージャンボミニがあったんですけど
サマージャンボ6億あたる方は連番を張ってさまざまミニ6000万の方はバラを
6億ですよ皆さん録音降ったら何しますお父様に1億マミー強くじいちゃんばあちゃん
に直弟に500円だぜ顔れますさあロックを買ったら何にすっていう
まあそれだねまぁ当たったような考えましょう the いきました6億
声んだお前ら本当に申し訳ない歩いよ完全に
ここで差がつくわけだ白磁っていうのはやっぱり顔ないが当たらないんですよ
確率は低いよ低いけど低いけどやっぱり買わないとその当選券自体がないから
5止めキター
どうせどっちじゃない効果じゃまずはかレイクと6000万のパパッターちゃんって
感じでいきましょう
サマーじょんのびにから行けます
これを了承していくのはお前だこんなんやってますまず6と300円
下一桁が8万熱
oo さんびゃあー7まずは300円で300円です
2つ以後と6000円ば死後3桁が15発15発
死亡初15発
以後発す用レーザ姉母2件んだよ
千葉さんへ546
546親6
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
んだけど6万円です
主モンユさん越後4桁の320生
おいなーい ov まずで消し迷うけど2512
はぁ13たち初67ん
ふぉあー196678
ホはいい
ら概要600万ディ600万兄くん
h 34となっている
フォア打つ元和あたってやいいんじゃあまあ俺は違うんですよ
あの6せーなー別に良いんぼカマロ降下するんです
ナマズの実にはサブ4件でした yeah
そう
次で次々でも完全にかしに行くからね第決まっています本気モーロックをかけたんです
ここはこれやばい連番だからなんか釣り程度はた瞬間も負け決定だから
ん
まずは300円です
救難
はいマザー300円結さん税下に行けた樽ってます
問題だ年版だから駄目ってすぐわかる
2屋さんと100万円です
1467悪いざー
4 r 2
r ん
ん
うぜ